hello everyone this next game is simply
a brilliant positional masterpiece by
Bobby Fischer and the reason I enjoyed
this game so much is because he's
playing Tigran Petrosian a guy who was
extremely hard to beat and this is their
1971
candidates match Fischer won at six and
a half to two and a half and with a
results like that and we can pretty much
say that well he crushed the iron tiger
in this game Bobby Fischer is white and
he plays efore we have c5 but Petrosyan
the Sicilian defense tonight we have
three e6 v4c chapters on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and now a six and here
Bobby plays Bishop to d3 we have a
knight to c6 Knight captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and Bobby castles and now
patron plays b5 and in this position
Bobby plays an extremely nice move he
plays c4 and with the idea Bobby wants
to exchange everything in the center and
this will leave black with an isolated D
pawn and even if black would capture the
the C pawn or D point then he would be
left with an isolated sheep on himself
and with an isolated a pawn and this
would be a lot better for white so we
have Knight to f6 by petroleum we have C
capture some d5 see characters on d5 e
caps or some d5 and D captures of me
five and now this V pawn is isolated in
Fischer will create a target of this
pawn so we have a Knight to c3 attacking
the pawn we have Bishop to e7 and now
Fischer plays Queen to a4 with check he
invites the chosen to play Queen to d7
to exchange Queens and well Petrosyan
isn't bad at playing the endgame himself
so he plays Queen to d7 and we have a
rook to e1 by Fischer so Petrosyan
captures the Queen Queen captures on a4
Knight captures an a4 and now Bishop to
e6 by petroleum and Bishop to e3
we have castles and now she's replaced a
Bishop to c5 he wants to exchange more
pieces to to go for the endgame
we have rook to e8 and now Fischer
captures Bishop captures only seventh
row casters and e7 and the future plays
b4 and with this
couple of exchanges Fisher now has this
nice and a four but he pushes b4 and
creates an extremely strong outpost for
this night on c5 and since since black
doesn't have a dark square Bishop to
this it will be very hard to oppose this
night on c5 so we have King 2f 8 and 9 I
see 5 and now nice now this Knight is a
monster and also by playing Knight e5 he
plays it with a tempo attacking the a6
born
so the rosin plays a bishop to see it
defending the pawn we have f3 by Fischer
and now rook e to 8 a 7 he doubles up on
da file the guard is pawn one more time
because he wants to activate his the
light square Bishop if he doesn't play
this rook d7 move then this Bishop will
be stuck on c7 defending this a 6 point
so we have roped the e5 by Fischer and
now Bishop to Bishop to d7 and in this
position
well the engines are giving a lot of
suggestions here for example one
suggestion is a 4 because the Petrosyan
wants to play Bishop to b5 and well
either activates his own Bishop or
exchange it for 4 Fischer's very active
Bishop and also the engine gives
suggestions like wrote the c1 and the
King to f2 and maybe g4 but the next
move Fischer place is nowhere in in
engine suggestions and the the moon
Fischer played next he was praised for
this move for 4 generations to come and
actually not as the players that were
watching this game none of the
grandmasters even considered this name
but this is this is the Y fisheries is
one of the strongest players in chess
history he actually plays nice captures
on d7 he gives up this monster night for
this world the soon to be activated
Bishop and what's the idea behind this
move well let's see Petrosyan plays rook
captures on d7 and now Fischer place
rook to c1 and the official finds a very
nice tactic to activate his rook and now
this rook is completely active and to
control the C file completely and what's
the idea if black was to play play a
slow move for example like h6
Fisher can simply capture this a six
pawn and the bishop cannot be captured
because if rook captures Bishop then
simply rip the ch-check and this is made
to follow
so after route to c1 Petrosian of course
sees this and well he has to defend this
pawn one more time AC if he plays rook
to a7 then well both of his rooks are
out of the game and this will be easily
when winning so person tries rook to d6
and we have a rook to c7 by Fisher
because petrosyan has to have to move
the rope from the seventh rank and now
Fischer occupies it we have nice a d7
attacking the rook rope goes to e - we
have g6 making some breathing space for
the King Fisher plays King to have to
improving the position of his own king
we have h5 we have f 4h for king - the
king - f3 we have F five Kings to e3 and
now Petrosyan pushes d4 and now King to
d2 and I want you to really look at this
position because this is this position
is so beautiful if you if you just look
at the position you'll see that there is
no move Petrosyan can play this is move
30 of the game and Petrosyan can't move
anything so this is a complete soup
swung in in move 30 this works has to
remain here if this rock is moved and
the Fischer will simply play rook to a7
and camp's ready a sec spawn the King
cannot go nowhere if he moves from the F
file for example to the G file then
Fischer will simply drop a rock to e7
and well this is over only moves that
Petrosyan could maybe play our rook to
d5 and King to f7 but after Bishop to c4
well the person will simply have to put
the piece back and this will only
improve Fischer's position
so after this a king to D to move like I
said the frozen has no move and well he
tries he tries an idea he plays nice to
b6 and he allows Fischer to play rook to
e7 and okay this does seem like the
rosin can now fork the fork the rooks
but
is not really going to win in Europe and
petroleum knows this but he thought that
maybe he could snatch this at for porn
so we have a nicety 5 forking the rooks
an official place to corrupt the f7
check we have Kings TV 8 and now moving
the other book out of harm's way
so rook to b7 and here petrosyan played
Knight captures on f4 and Fischer plays
Bishop to c4 and in this position that
rosin resigned
there is no move again that the Trojan
could play because there is no simply no
stopping of the threat that is ruk to h7
rook to e7 and group the h8 checkmate
and this is unstoppable if you try
something like for example 926 then
simply a rook to e7 will pick up the
night
Petrosyan Petra before the frozen
captured this pawn he did have one more
chance as trying to preserve this game
although still it would have been lost
because this a a six bond will fall he
could have placed something like rook to
b8 but this only dis only prolongs the
unstoppable so
Petrosyan decided to snatch this pawn on
f4 and after Bishop to c4 Petrosian
resigned and yeah like I said a
beautiful positional masterpiece I mean
crushing patrolling like that forcing an
endgame against the great endgame player
like Petrosyan and then winning not only
this game but he have won four games in
a row against the Trojan in this match
and yeah it's just beautiful and for the
end of this video I did hear a funny
story but petrosyan let you decide for
yourselves if this is true when frozen
became world champion it seems that he
became so popular that a woman had
triplets in Armenia and he she named
them Tigran Watson and Petros as in the
theorem baton which Petrosyan just to
honor the guy I don't really think this
is true but then again you never know so
yeah that's it for this video I do hope
you enjoyed it and the usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
that's it thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon oh and meadow says hi